Salam alaikum guys I'm with Nabil said
I'm buddy and he accepted Islam not too
long ago a couple years ago yeah
what was it I started thinking about
virtue and goodness and truth
I was torn about the way things are I
want to walk around I see things I see a
lot of terrible things happening my
father had passed away a couple of
months before and I was really upset I
kind of stopped beating stop sleeping I
stopped going to work and this was for
like two weeks and I just really wanted
to I just was really upset about
everything I was just so upset and I
knew about of law from reading some
books and stuff I miss them but so I
feel like I had a connection with my law
walking around knowing the signs are
everywhere
I asked Allah to help me and went to
subdued and I asked verse hell and right
there I knew I had to become Muslim
started to read Quran and I started to
learn about miss them and I knew I had
to learn how to pray and I just was so
happy cuz that I was so certain that I
found the truth and the answers I was
looking for my whole life and in my
heart I just meet other Muslims you go
to the Masjid you meet these people and
it's it's the beauty that I knew was
there but I couldn't find it right as an
American like I they don't tell you
about it in schools really like they
don't they don't even it's like it
doesn't even exist like the Koran they
don't even tell you about it I'm from
kind of a small town in Massachusetts
and maybe bigger cities they kind of
maybe tell you about it but they just
don't really tell you about it so much I
mean you have to find it yourself you
know huh how long has it been now it's
been almost three years now three years
since you took your shavon yeah and for
those I don't know show houses which
someone accept Islam is that testimony
of faith declaring that there's nothing
worthy of worship except the creator of
the heavens and earth the muhammed is
the seal of the prophets and this will
automatically include i exclude jesus
moses abraham and all the preceding
messengers who came the same message
submit your will to god's will worship
the creator not the creation before
islam
what was your way of life were you
Christian Jewish and you I mean what
kind of religion were you practicing or
were you not practicing where you
wouldn't were your parents apart I'm
from Massachusetts oh it's a lot of
Catholics there it's a lot of Irish
Catholics but my family wasn't Catholic
my great-grandmother was involved with
the Catholic Church and she had had an
abusive husband I was told who beat her
and the kids I was told and she left the
church because they wouldn't even grant
her a divorce so she said goodbye so she
became a Unitarian so my parents are
Unitarian so I think that kind of
instilled in me something but where they
weren't very religious we didn't really
go to church they kind of were always
like it's up to you to decide for
yourself and they believed in you know
ethic ethical living and my father was
very by-the-book you know he right is
right and wrong is wrong and you don't
do something just because it's wrong
it's simple and I got him into yoga
pretty heavily and I practice yoga for a
long time but it just left me with more
questions and I think it helped focus me
on unity aslam as the Paris community
it's you know the oneness of Allah so
that kind of interested me for a while
but I just eventually found us that I
just just so happy that I 70 sometimes
it's a it's hard to find like you were
saying and when someone does to stumble
upon Islam it's usually covered with a
lot of dirt meaning there's a lot of
misconceptions people equated with you
know some radical crazy terrorists right
right
violence was that kind of in your way in
the beginning did you feel like you know
okay because people they'll try every
other religion okay Buddhism dishes and
that ISM and it's kind of cool and
whatnot you know but as soon as Islam
you know comes in the picture there's a
stigma attached to a song right right so
people just like no you know I don't
want to deal with that because I
probably get some heat backlash and
whatnot did you have any of that
trepidation yeah a little bit I mean I
kind of knew reading some poetry like
The Roommate and used to have the things
like there's we know we're not getting
the truth I mean anyone who sits down I
think and thinks about it know that that
what we're seeing you know shown to us
and the words they use to portray this
and what's happening and you know you
have to sit down and think about it and
that's kind of what I how I felt you
know there's much more to it than thin
bends on the surface you know so I was
thinking deeply about it didn't it again
it's how does it relate to me in my life
not some other people in some other
country what they say is happening and
the reasons they're doing things or this
but how does it relate to me house how
do i how do I feel about this person in
my experience you know so I kind of
looked at it like that one of the things
that made me think about a little bit
more was was the women thinking about
how women are and how the women who want
to be Muslims like there's there
sometimes attacked saying they're
oppressed or they're there for stood
there and I just I knew that this isn't
the case like they're they feel like
they have a higher purpose like they're
there guarding themselves to try to
protect their after their afterlife and
I started thinking about that you know
the afterlife
you know there's a reason why we're all
we're doing
what we do matters you know we're bound
by virtue and that's what I kind of kept
saying to myself it's truth bound by
virtue I just get pondering on this you
know our actions our deeds they matter
and then also the concept of God is that
you know it's it's not really people
it's hard to save it it's it's different
here like Allah knows our hearts who
knows our deepest secrets
he knows inside our our minds you know
like this type of this type of concept
you know there's a little bit foreign to
people you know thinking but I start
parting on that and you know you know
knowing that he's there with us all the
time you know he why wouldn't he know I
even created us you know it's so
beautiful to know that day that he's
there with us all the time you know we
can count on him to help us I mean
that's the thing we encourage people who
are stuck in life to want to know more
about life Islam has everything laid out
it's a beautiful way of life and you
found it you're living it
you got a purpose now some deadlines
what advice do you have for other people
who are going through life and it just
you know there's no satisfaction but the
heart is empty
right and they're tuning into the Deen
show yeah I've talked me to give advice
to anyone I'd say look inside your heart
and know that all laws there you know
pour your heart out to Allah go to
subdued stay there as long as you can
let the tears flow ask a lot of open
your heart and that's simple advice but
profound indeed Jesus did it did you
know that he made that so dude that's
the prostration and as it says and he
went a little further and he fell on his
face and prayed to who to
and he called on telling you Allah Jesus
called on Aloha that's the same creator
so call upon the Creator and ask for
guidance and take it from there
thank you so much thank you very much
thank you hey guys hi tonight every
Masjid I want to see you should need
when you walk into a Masjid I mean to
tackle the ignorance that's out there
people not knowing these knowledge is
important so I love when you come to the
mustard how does he look
he's pamphlets Jesus in Islam did you
know that look at that unveiling the
mystery hijab you don't worry that
Jesus's mother marries the whole chapter
named after her in the Quran and the
list goes on
look at that what they say about
Mohammed learn about the last and final
messenger problem honey peace supposed
to be upon him I'm down the Quran
everything is here
someone denied yet Muslims come and
visit now you can go ahead and share the
sharing is caring
I remember if you don't have these
download materials you can contact game
piece and we can set you guys up with
some of the brochures it's extremely
important especially during these times
of misunderstanding but Melissa should
always be doing dowel sharing conveying
the message so I'll make